[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america
crazier than most
let's find out what happened
a new mexico man last week allegedly
pulled a gun on a mcdonald's employee
following a mistake in his order
officials are calling it
not even close to the craziest thing
that happened
last week following last week's capital
riot the acting u.s
attorney for washington d.c said he's
never seen a crime scene with such a
diversity of charges
though i have to say i've seen the
photos and diversity was not the first
word that came to mind
in a statement about last week's u.s
capitol riot
first lady melania trump said there has
been salacious
gossip about her though it's hard to
imagine gossip about her life that could
be worse
than the truth take it out take down
take down
you guys you should have to look at that
and i'm sorry that i made you
jeez louise
well i mean what is worse than that
i'm aware it's not nice but isn't it
true
singer mary j blige turned 50 this week
and so did a white woman
that nice is that nice she's given the
look though she's like ah
i need to go because
i didn't choose this picture and i do
not endorse this joke
but my laughter stands according to a
new study
children that are well behaved are more
likely to live happier and healthier
adult lives
this threat was first issued by grandma
marcy
do you want to live sit down buckingham
palace announced that queen elizabeth ii
and prince philip received the
coronavirus vaccine
so now all they have to worry about is a
stiff breeze
look at him he'll do oh
[Applause]
president there are no adults here no
how is this camera being operated by who
president trump told reporters on
tuesday that efforts to impeach him for
a second time were quote
a continuation of the greatest witch
hunt in the history of politics
and then he boarded air force one and
flew away
finally his feet are up his feet are
playing he's spry
he's spry you would not think that his
knees would get that bend but they do
yeah because he's a witch because he's a
witch
and finally rapper nicki minaj recently
agreed
to pay 450 000
to singer tracy chapman to settle a
copyright lawsuit
so now tracy can finally afford a ticket
to anywhere
there you go that was the monologue that
was a choice i made
yeah does that exist i don't stand by
that that tracy chapman joke
it's from my heart and that was the
monologue turk while i was doing that
monologue did you try to overthrow any
governments
i did not crazy how easy it is not to do
that
yeah now amber we covered a lot of news
in that monologue but i feel like
there's one little bit of news we missed
do you have some personal news i do
you guys i wrote a book with my sister
and it's out this week
it's called you'll never believe what
happened to lacey crazy story is about
racism
my sister lacy lives in omaha nebraska
and this book is about all the crazy
racist things that people say to her in
her daily life
while she's minding her own business
you're not going to believe it
uh it's funny and it's infuriating and
it comes with a very cute picture of my
sister on it
look but then look over here oh
i'm cuter i'm cuter and that's how we
sound thank you i'm cute i'm cute
you can get it wherever you get books
and
that oh and we read the uh
the audio version it's me and lacy
yapping back and forth
so if this sound hasn't made you start
to cry you gotta go ahead
get them you can get it wherever books
are sold
and that was a personal news now let's
get back to the news news
hey tarek focus up oh sorry
now the last 10 months have been a truly
dark time for america but
one bright little ray of hope is peeking
through
starting on january 20th democrats will
have control of the house
the senate and the white house for the
first time in over a decade
and it's so exciting and crazy and
unexpected
i haven't even had a chance to process
what all the implications are
for the country going forward it's just
like
tarik do you know what this means what
americans might get stimulus checks that
actually provide them with some stimulus
do you know what this means people under
50 might actually get the covet vaccine
before 20 30. 2030.
hey do you know what this means nazis
will still be in congress but now
they're in the minority do you know what
this means
red maga hats will still be scary but
now
we could say it's because of racism and
not economic anxiety
do you know what this means i can take
down that cardboard cutout of a white
guy i put in my window home alone style
to make sure nobody busts my door down
do
you know what this means we might
actually get
a health care system a real health care
system and i might be able to get this
mole looked at
what this means do you do you know what
this means
we can finally do something about
climate change like what
like this whoa
is this helping i don't know but we can
finally do this
yeah come on no but seriously you should
get that mole looked at
yeah it talks to me now democrats taking
control of the senate
isn't the only recent news that shocked
america
there's another piece of news i heard
this week that i want to tell you about
but
i want to be very careful delivering it
because i think it may be shocking for
some of you watching at home
in fact it may be shocking for some of
us here in the studio too
tarek what's up amber tarik apparently
some of the rioters who stormed the
capitol on wednesday
some of them were off-duty police
officers
what no
oh that's really good okay now my turn
you told me the news
okay all right uh amber
i don't know if you know this if you've
heard about this
but some of the people who stormed the
capitol building
were off-duty cops what
no the cops
that was good that was good all right
let me try again
how how could this happen i feel
betrayed
good good now i mean they're supposed to
protect us my whole world is upside down
nothing makes sense anymore
the gums the cops
and scenes
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
the news is a never-ending [ __ ] storm of
poop dookie and doo-doo
so i wanted to take a second and shine a
light on something positive that
happened recently
in a segment called hero of the week
[Music]
last week a video went viral of capital
police officer eugene goodman
being chased up the stairs by a crowd of
pro-trump rioters
during the attack on the u.s capitol
goodman knew that the floor of the
senate chamber had not been secured yet
so
he intentionally provoked the rioters
into chasing him and then
led them away from the chamber giving
senators time to evacuate safely
let's give a round of applause to this
hero
that sound means america was saved by a
black person
again which brings us to a new segment
within a segment called
why do black people always have to save
america
[Music]
america's history with african americans
is violent and
oppressive and yet time and time again
america's savior seems to be the exact
people who should want to burn it down
most
from the black men and women who were
enslaved and forced to build a country
in which
they weren't seen as full people to the
men who were pushed to the front lines
of wars and then came back home
and couldn't even get a burger at a
diner that you know was under season
because it was whites only
to stacy abrams and the other organizers
who turned georgia blue this month
with which without hyperbole may have
literally saved our democracy
to make it frank america doesn't deserve
the grace we continuously give it which
brings me to
a new segment within a segment within a
segment called should black people stop
saving america
yes the crazy thing is that
even though we know black people would
be 100 satisfied in not saving america
you know we'll never stop because like i
said this country was built on the backs
of our ancestors
no matter how bad white supremacists
fight to oppress and suppress
us it won't work and officer goodman is
proof because
even when we're outnumbered one to a
thousand
we still somehow will manage to end up
hero
of the week
[Music]
you